so now we'll look at a third kind of sum
that comes up all the time called
harmonic sums and we'll begin by
examining an example where they come up
really directly so here's the puzzle
suppose that I'm trying to stack a bunch
of books on a table assuming all the
books are the same size and weight and
uniform and I'd like to stack them up
one on top of the other in some way and
try to get them as far out past the end
of the table as I can manage now notice
in this picture it seems kind of
paradoxical the top book the the back
end of the top book is past the edge of
the table is it possible to do that is
it possible to get the top book though
the back of the top book past the edge
of the table and how far out can you get
the furthermost book to the right that's
the question we want to ask well let's
go back and do it for the simplest case
which is one book so this amount will be
a function of how many books we have
we're interested in the overhang using n
books overhang is the amount past the
edge of the table that the rightmost on
end of any book can be okay
what do you do with one book well with
one book assuming that the thing is
uniform the center of mass is in the
middle assume the book is of length one
so the center of mass of the book is at
halfway down the book and if that center
of mass is not over the table then
you're gonna have torque and the book is
going to fall so you've got to keep the
center of mass supported and the way to
get the largest overhang is to have the
center of mass right at the edge of the
table here and in that case you can get
the book to stick out half a book length
without falling and what that tells us
is that the one book overhang is 1/2
it'll balance with the farthest end out
exactly at the center of mass is on the
edge and I get a half a book length from
unit overhang all right let's proceed
recursively or inductively suppose I
have n books how am I gonna get them to
balance well let's assume that I figured
out how to get a so-called stable stack
of n books which if I complete
supported it flat on the table it
wouldn't fall over and I'm gonna show
you how to go from n to n plus one which
is how you construct an arbitrarily
large stack of books that won't fall
over well if the stack of completely
resting on the table won't fall over
that means that if it if I have the
center of mass of it past the edge of
the table by definition at the center of
mass there's gonna be an equal amount of
weight on both sides of the center of
mass and the thing is gonna fall off the
edge of the table by the same reasoning
as we did for one book so the the stable
and stacked stable in the sense that
it'll it won't fall over of itself if it
was lying completely over the table in
fact it won't fall over as long as its
center of mass is over the table and to
get it out the furthest amount to the
right what I'm going to do is put it at
the edge of the table okay so now I know
how to place a table stack of n books to
get the largest overhang out of it what
next well let's consider n plus 1 books
and what do I have to do so I'm trying
to do the same deal suppose that I have
a nice stack of n books and I know how
to support it so it won't tip over and I
now have n books and plus 1 books and I
want to get out further what do I have
to do well by the basic reasoning that
we just went through now the center of
mass of the whole stack of n plus 1
books has to be over the edge of the
table that's the way I'm gonna get out
the furthest so I know where the center
of mass of n plus books are gonna be at
the edge of the table okay what about
the center of mass of the top and books
and well I need them to be supported I
need their center of mass to be
supported they'll be supported providing
their center of mass is over the bottom
book somewhere and the way to get it out
furthest is to have it over the right
edge of the bottom book so I'm gonna put
the center of mass of the top and books
at the edge of the n plus first book
here yeah and that means that the
increment or overhang that I get the
increase in overhang that I get by
adding one more book we can call the
delta overhang and it's the distance
between the
center of mass of n plus-1 books and the
center of mass of n books and n here and
n plus one here well let's see what's
going on the center of mass of thee n
books is at some location here and the
center of mass of the bottom book is
half way away half a book length away
from where the end books are balanced on
the edge of the bottom book so the
center of mass of the end books is here
the center of mass of the bottom book is
there the distance between them is one
half and I need the table to be at the
balance point between the end books and
the one book that's where the center of
mass of the n plus one books will be so
I need to calculate amount that's going
to be the increase in overhang so let's
abstract it a little bit the delta
overhang is the distance from the end
book to the n plus one book centers of
mass and if we think of this as a
balancing diagram there's the end books
or at least there's the center of mass
of the end books there's the center of
mass of the one book their distance
one-half apart which we said and they
have to balance at the edge of the table
so think of the edge of the table as the
pivot point and it's there and I need to
calculate where is that pivot point how
do I get this fulcrum or this balance
beam to balance with weight and here and
weight one there when they're a total
length apart is a half what's this
distance that distance is the Delta that
I'm trying to calculate well you just
know from physics that the balance point
is going to be the distance 1/2 divided
by the sum of N and n plus 1 ok I need
the end times this amount to equal 1
times that amount and if you check that
out it means that Delta is 1/2 over n
plus 1 or simplifying 1 over twice n
plus 1 now you should stare at that
diagram a little bit and remember your
elementary physics to realize the
reasoning behind the formula for Delta
okay well now I'm done because basically
I've just figured out that the increase
is this Delta over hang and now I know
what it is it's 1 over twice n plus 1
and so what I can conclude is that
overhang of n books B 1 is 1/2 and B n
plus 1 is B n plus 1 over twice and plus
1 so this is a recursive definition of
BN but it's easy to see how it unwinds
it means that BN is 1/2 plus 1 one half
of one plus one plus one half of two
plus one plus one half of three plus one
and so on if i factor out the 1/2 BN is
1/2 times 1 plus 1/2 plus 1/3 out
through 1 over n ok that sum is the
harmonic sum the sum 1 plus 1/2 up
through 1 over N is called HN or the
harmonic some and what we figured out or
really the harmonic number is the value
of that sum and B what we figured out is
that BN the amount that I can get n
books out of passed the edge of the
table is H n over 2